gender is the term that was first
introduced
uh
in the 50s
uh by John money psychologist John money
at Johns Hopkins University
he invented this idea that we have a
psychological sex
not just a biological sex but a
psychological sex in our mind
and that we are born gender neutral
so that when we're born even a normal
child
uh he he proposed is born without any uh
propensity or quality you know masculine
or feminine qualities yes there were
certain physical characteristics
obviously that were different but aside
from those areas
everything else is imposed by Society a
social construct
so all the sort of so-called feminine
qualities of being nurturing and you
know preferring to play with dolls
instead of uh instead of trucks and uh
interest in
uh the more nurturing professions and uh
being more uh maybe verbal and
articulate I mean all these kind of
stereotypical
uh things so John money proposed that
this is all imposed by Society
a social construct but in addition he
came up with this revolutionary theory
that because that's the case and we are
all born gender neutral
that therefore a boy could be
successfully raised as a girl
and a girl as a boy it all dependent on
environment he had an one experiment he
did one his proof of concept of his
theory of gender identity being uh being
that we're born uh uh gender neutral and
that it's all about society and that
it's all about gender identity and that
it's flu all that stuff
was PR his proof of concept failed utter
miserably it could not have failed more
but
it only became known that it had failed
after about
25 30 years after he began saying that
it was a success
so there was a long delay
in uh the discovery that the individuals
that he had experimented on the boy that
was raised as a girl because he had had
his penis burnt off during a
circumcision and his parents took him to
Johns Hopkins to see Dr money Dr money
said raise this boy as a girl and he
will be fine we'll castrate him we'll do
some surgery we'll give him some
hormones at the right time he'll be
absolutely fine they listened to him
they tried it it was a disaster he ended
up killing himself
he never felt like a girl he never acted
like a girl and his biology was coming
through loud and clear
that Y chromosome that tiny little Y
chromosome makes a big difference
now
by the time that David Riemer this boy
that was raised as a girl
came out publicly and said my life was a
disaster because of John money
I was exploited by the medical field and
not only that but John money's results
when John money went and said that I
speaking in other words David speaking
now that I was a success and that I
actually felt like a girl
this you know you have to understand I
mean it's it's impossible to believe
here isn't it you see David reamer was
was the perfect perfect uh uh subject
for for John money he was a twin he had
an identical twin so he and they were of
course raised in the same environment
the same family this was the perfect
setup it was the answer to John money's
prayers
and so they do this experiment and this
little boy is told from the age of about
18 months that he's a girl
okay he's still in diapers
and he's told he's a girl he's given the
name Brenda he's put in dresses uh the
whole world all his relatives and this
is the perfect
social trans we would call it socially
transitioning right now except that the
kid himself didn't know that he was
being socially transitioned
the book that came out published telling
his story
is called as nature made him by John
colopinto came out in 1999.
it was before John money died
John money his whole life never made any
public statements regarding what
happened in other words public
statements acknowledging the disaster of
his experiment
why is it that now that we know what
happened to those twins
and did I say they both committed
suicide or did I just say David
they both commit well the other his
identical twin uh died of a of an
overdose
so he destroyed a family John money and
he was every time the kids were taken
down to see him because they lived in uh
Canada and the parents would take them
down once a year to see John money John
money was sexually abusing those kids
and he was showing them pornography
uh he in his mind well he was
pro-pornography he he felt that that
kids needed to see in order to develop
normally uh in terms of their sexuality
he believed that uh all children needed
to be exposed to graphic sexual images
and he was also for incest he was
publicly pro-incest so this is a wicked
guy
my question is if this man has been
discredited if his research was found to
have to to not have any scientific value
then why is it that these ideas are
still being propagated today
bingo
foreign